- men and women of God and goodwill
everywhere flight black and otherwise if
you believe all are created equal
come to Selma join us join our march
against injustice and inhumanity we need
you to stand with us yes this shouldn't
start I start the Peace of thing
together I need you to step back and
allow me to handle this my first
priority is my daughter
i I need seven you need seven seven
groomsmen I do you have any idea what
you're asking for you asking me to pull
off a golden tux
yes see I don't see that on this
pamphlet here it's not on the pamphlet
because what you're talking about is
what we joke about around here you want
to call in ketchup ketchup the bear done
adding time oh sorry a lot of guys lost
more than just a leg mhm mhm you lose
some friends well they do but I'm
talking about the guys that lived you
know they made it back but they're just
not I just not back you know they can't
seem to get right yep mm-hmm
why don't you come down to the VA
sometime guys I love it
they all know who the legend is my
family thanks you for your service